uh not a video game but reality for the
national football league and a delicate
situation without question for the
steelers and for the league office james
harrison former steelers linebacker
appearing on a barstool podcast you guys
causing trouble again for the nfl going
deep is the name of the podcast here is
james harrison talking about a 2010 fine
that was imposed upon him for an illegal
hit on brown's receiver mohammed
massaqua and what coach mike tomlin did
after that fine was levied against
harrison
the most you've ever been fined in one
game one game was 75. oh
is that the master quad hit
yeah
dude how you gonna find me for dude oh
listen listen listen listen um listen
everything i love my daddy's gray i hit
that man with about
max 50 of what i had and i just hit him
because i wanted him to let loose the
ball
if i had knew they was going to find me
75 000.
i would have tried to kill him
dude
i'm telling you right
75
and people said i ain't going to lie to
you i ain't gonna lie to you but that
happened right
and uh
the jesus thing mike tyler ever did
he handed me an envelope after that
yeah he ended me an envelope and james
harrison said i won't say what was in it
but he handed me an envelope so we
reached out to the league office we
reached out to the steelers
what comment if any does the league and
does the team have about something that
would have been a violation of the rules
look if a guy gets fined you can't pay
that fine you can't reward a guy for
legal hits or illegal hits the bounty
scandal two years later prove that
conclusively art rooney ii issuing this
statement i'm very certain nothing like
this ever happened i have no idea why
james would make a comment like this but
there is simply no basis for believing
anything like this big cat let's discuss
this
i
would like to see what mike tomlin has
to say about it
unless art rooney the second was part of
the conversation between harrison and
tomlin how does rooney know one way or
the other i want a statement from tomlin
not from rooney i i appreciate the fact
that rooney went on the record and at
the time rooney went on the record and
said he thought the hit for which
harrison was fined was legal but now
rooney's on the record saying there's no
basis for it let's hear what tomlin has
to say
okay so uh break this down for me mike
first of all shout out to uh the going
deep podcast willie clone and stephen
shay formerly the surf n turf podcast
forgetting this story great story to get
in a time when there are no sports mike
is it the hypocrisy if the nfl doesn't
do anything because i've always been of
the mindset that this type of stuff
happens in every single locker room in
the nfl and that was why the bounty gate
thing seemed a little ridiculous at the
time because yes you d i would prefer
them not to do this i'd prefer there not
to be bounties on players heads but to
say this doesn't happen between players
and of course when coaches get involved
it's a little bit of a different
situation but to to to go into an nfl
locker room and not expect to have this
happen off of big hits big plays
whatever you want to call it you would
be absolutely naive and foolish so is it
that the nfl has to act and and
investigate to the lengths that they did
the saints and sean payton being
suspended for a year or is it that this
should never happen ever because we need
to take this out of the sport where do
you land on this
here's how i think the nfl handles it if
this is something that had happened post
bounty scandal in 2012 the nfl would
have done something about it because i
think the message to all teams at the
time the nfl imposed over the top
penalties on coach sean payton on
defensive coordinator greg williams on
players the player suspensions
eventually were eradicated by former
commissioner paul tagliabue the message
was no more of this stuff no more
bounties no more payment for legal hits
no more payment for illegal hits we're
not going to do this we are now
sensitive to health and safety this
doesn't mesh with health and safety
rewarding players for incapacitating
opponents the fact that it happened
before the bounty scandal puts it in my
mind big cat into the category of things
the nfl doesn't want to know about the
nfl didn't go down the rabbit hole of
all the various other bounty scandals we
became aware of especially wherever greg
williams had been before he was with the
saints the nfl didn't want to do that
the nfl didn't want to disclose to the
world that there's an inherently corrupt
organization right under its nose where
every team is doing this in some form or
fashion and actually you could make the
argument that if what harrison's saying
is the truth and look i i haven't and i
got to go back and do the research and
see if he's got an axe to grind with
mike tomlin this didn't come off like a
disgruntled employee telling on his
former boss he appreciates him he just
is oblivious to the fact that it may
create a problem right so yeah
i mean do you first of all let's
establish that well this doesn't seem
like somebody who's trying to blow the
whistle on tomlin this is somebody who's
applauding tomlin correct
yes absolutely correct it's the exact
opposite of blowing the whistle i think
james harrison is saying that mike
tomlin is a player's coach that is a guy
who is in tune with the locker room and
would go up to a player like that
afterwards not because hey good hit
because it was a penalty so not a good
hit way to go here's money it was a
you're about to get fined i'm gonna
cover some of that fine that's a
player's coach situation so yes i
completely agree he's not whistleblowing
on mike tomlin he's instead saying mike
tomlin is a great coach and knows how to
take care of his players
now you could argue that what happened
here if it did happen is worse than what
happened in the saints case because
there was no evidence in the saints case
that players were being rewarded for
illegal hits that incapacitated
opponents the idea was there was an
incentive to go out there and within the
confines of the rules hit your opponent
so aggressively so hard so violently the
opponent couldn't continue you had to
tap out and leave the game but not with
an illegal hit that was a point we made
over and over again back in 2012 this
isn't a tonya harding jeff galuli
situation where you're trying to commit
a criminal act that keeps a guy from
playing this is playing the game within
the confines of the rules in a way that
causes your opponent to not be able to
continue in this case you've got the
possibility that the head coach rewarded
slash compensated a player who committed
a violation of the rules paying him for
an illegal hit and here's the
rationalization for it i think big cat
when you consider that at the time
both mike tomlin and art rooney ii came
out and said
this was a legal hit and this was at a
time when the nfl teams were getting
their arms around the reality that hits
that used to be okay aren't going to be
okay this was the day in october of 2010
when it was james harrison hitting
muhammad massaqua brandon merriweather
hitting todd heap and dante robinson
hitting deshawn jackson all in bang bang
bang fashion 15 minutes of real time
that's when we all kind of said whoa
these hits to the head of players who
are in the process of catching passes
have to end
at the time though there were coaches
and owners who said wait a minute why
does this have to end this is legal so
my point is i could see mike tomlin
justifying compensating james harrison
for the fine if tomlin genuinely
believes the fine was inappropriate i
disagree with this fine they've screwed
my player i'm giving my player the money
that he lost because of this fine and
again harrison didn't say what he
received but i'm giving my player an
envelope an envelope because he got
screwed and i believe he got screwed and
my boss believes he got screwed so it's
plausible to me that it happened when we
consider the specific circumstances that
were around the sport at the time and
the attitudes of especially guys like
mike tomlin as the nfl was getting
itself comfortable with eradicating
these kinds of hits from the game
and you said it at the top the fact that
it happened before bountygate and the
league changing everything and trying to
to take this out of the game i think
makes a a huge difference when when
we're talking about what the league will
do whether they'll investigate if this
was a story from james harrison from
three years ago it's a totally different
ball game for mike tomlin because
if a coach gets caught doing this today
it is all on the coach for doing
something that they know will get them
in trouble again i think this happens in
every locker room and i think it
continues to happen and i think that it
will happen for the rest of time because
it's no different than if you're
watching right now a little crossover
for you mike you know the last dance and
players playing cards on a plane and
players you know having a kitty in the
locker room where they all pull their
money together and they find each other
this is going to happen forever but when
the coach gets involved it's a little
different and because this was
pre-bounty gate i think mike tomlin is
going to escape any type of real
investigation here if it were in the
last couple years
then the nfl has to react because of
what sean payton said they went after
him they took away a year's salary of
you know of him they took away his job
for an entire year to not do something
similar if they if someone is found to
be guilty would be crazy
yeah and sean payton and greg williams
were proverbially not literally the
heads on a pike at the city gates to
remind anyone who may dare to do this in
the future of what will happen to you
and at the time and the reason why the
players ultimately french press were
vindicated by this paul tagliabue who
was assigned the responsibility for
resolving the players appeals of their
suspensions he said look this isn't how
you deal with a cultural issue you deal
with a cultural issue by telling all
teams we got a problem here it's
changing now and moving forward anybody
who violates this is going to get
hammered you don't just pick the first
team that you see that's violating a
rule that everyone's violating and say
we're gonna make an example out of them
to scare everyone else straight that's
why sean payton's upset he was the guy
who was made the example out of and
payton isn't happy about what's happened
now and payton believes i think
rightfully so that nothing is going to
happen with this situation peyton
appeared yesterday on 105 7 the fan in
baltimore with jason lock in four here's
sean payton discussing these new
allegations
if people are waiting for the league to
investigate that they shouldn't hold
their breath uh i i think you know what
took place with us back in 2011 in so
many ways was a sham um
and and yet there wasn't a lot we could
do with it you know the players were
vindicated but from a from a league or a
coaching standpoint there's no union
there's no representation but i would be
i would be shocked if uh that that'll be
something that's tucked away uh or under
the rug at park avenue they'll look into
it briefly
listen don't get me started on that i i
i i we're going to get you back in the
doghouse salary in in in honestly it was
it was uh it was something that you know
honestly something i'll never i'll never
truly get over because i know how it was
handled and how it was run and and how
it uh and the reasons behind it and
that's that's that's just the truth
i love sean payton because he will not
mince words he will not play politics he
will tell you what he believes he will
call it like he sees it and he's daring
the nfl to do something about his
comments and how could the nfl
punish him for saying what he said
yesterday while not investigating what
james harrison said so peyton has put
them in check possibly checkmate because
if they do lash out against him they
can't lash out or but if they lash out
against him they can't look the other
way on the james harrison mike tomlin
thing it's one or the other it can't be
both or whatever i'm trying to say they
know who we mean the point is peyton is
willing to say what he believes and i
love that comment and he's right they're
not going to investigate the league
declined comment when we asked them
about it yesterday now that doesn't mean
they're not doing anything about it
behind the scenes but this is something
that they just want to go away and it's
coming at the worst possible time big
cat because nothing else is going on so
people are going to be chasing this
story
yeah absolutely it it it's something
that you know mike florio and his little
uh army and narcs are going to be hot on
the case for a while that's true that's
true this is going to be a story that
you're going to watch out and you should
this is why we need you because there's
hypocrisy that is going that is taking
place right now and sean payton is not
wrong to say that they're going to just
not investigate and he's not wrong to
outright say i will never get over this
and what they how they handled it is
egregious and it's something that
probably sean payton should remind
people of more when when it comes to
like his public appearances and whatever
he's doing he should probably let people
know more that what happened wasn't
right and he's still not over it because
as time goes by people will forget that
he even missed a year so i'm i'm on sean
payton's side here i'm on your side mike
florio i do not think the nfl will do
anything because it was pre bounty gate
and
at the end of the day it's probably
gonna be a simple conversation with mike
tomlin mike tomlin will say no they'll
say okay cool and then they'll move on
don't they talk to james harrison though
don't they bring him in shouldn't they
bring him in and sit him down and say
what are you talking about here how much
money did it give you is this true did
you mean it and maybe james harrison
will clam up now that he realized he
stepped right into it but i i just think
that when we consider the things that
the league will investigate and
investigate and investigate some more
that have nothing to do with football
per se
why would you not look into this now
again we've already answered that
question the nfl doesn't want to go back
and pick at that scar of pre-bounty gate
mindset in the nfl as everyone was
getting comfortable with
reluctantly the idea that there are
certain hits that weren't going to be
allowed anymore let me give you an
example big cat to properly understand
the context here the following year 2011
ryan clark was fined forty thousand
dollars for an illegal helmet to helmet
hit on a defenseless player and what
clark said was
mike tomlin
told him
that it was a clean hit and tomlin used
the hit in the film room as an example
of a good
hit so and i remember at the time saying
if you're only going to find the players
and not find the coaches the coaches
aren't going to tell the players to not
do this because the money isn't coming
out of the coach's pocket unless of
course the coach is giving the players
an envelope when it happens coach wants
to win games and i think it took time
for guys like tomlin to realize that
this specific weapon was being removed
from the arsenal the intimidation factor
the brutality that comes from going in
hot helmet down on a guy who's catching
the football go back and watch any game
from the 70s 80s or 90s on youtube and
you'll see
exactly the kind of hits that are now
forbidden so it's not like turning on a
light you it takes time for the people
in the game to realize this isn't
allowed anymore and i think it took mike
tomlin some time and maybe along the way
big cat he decided i'm going to pay back
at least one of my players fines
let me ask you this mike were these hits
the james harrison and the ryan clark
that you just mentioned were they
penalties on the field
you know i don't know that because
there's been such a disconnect between
what happens in real time and what
happens when the league office looks at
it but let's remember again the context
it was in 2009 october when roger
goodell the commissioner of the game and
dee smith the head of the union were
called to a congressional subcommittee
hearing and congress put the fear of god
into them that it's time to wake up to
the dangers of concussions the following
october we had those three hits i
mentioned bang bang bang happened in 15
minutes of real time we ripped up the
outline for football night in america it
was the dominant topic of the night i
remember vividly tony dungy and rodney
harrison were great on
what these hits mean and how you get
guys to stop rodney said hey fines don't
matter it's a cost of doing business i
used to set money aside for fines only
if you suspend me am i going to stop
doing it i mean it was a great
conversation it set the narrative for
the coming week as people got their arms
around this the bottom line is the
officials were learning along with
everyone else and they were missing some
of these because a lot of these
officials spent their whole life seeing
these hits there's there's a clip from a
game in the mid 70s where mel blunt does
a pile driver on cliff branch and an
official just walks into the into the
scene nonchalantly and picks the ball up
and sets it for the next down i mean for
the longest time this kind of stuff was
perfectly acceptable in the nfl so it
took the it took the participants a
little while to get used to the new
reality i don't think that that hit was
a penalty because i'm looking you know
at the replay right there i don't i
don't see a penalty flag and it looks
like they're at the same point in the
field on the next play so that even
speaks more to mike tomlins out here he
has an out with it being pre-bounty gate
he has an out with just outright denying
it if he would like to and then he has
an outro out by saying i disagreed with
the league's ruling here so it's not a
situation where james harrison gets a
15-yard penalty on the field and then
mike tomlin says good job man we'll take
those 15-yard penalties if you can
intimidate the opponent that's a
different conversation he's simply
saying that was a hit that i thought was
legal they obviously later on didn't i'm
going to help you out with the font
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports